In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, from May 19th, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Dunston, Archbishop of Canterbury.
On the 19th of the month, we celebrate the memory of our venerable Father Dunston, Archbishop
of Canterbury.
Dunston was born in about 924 in Balton's Bro near Glastonbury.
His father, Hurston, was a noble Saxon from the West, and his mother, Sinnerthritth, a woman
of holy life, was given a miraculous revelation of the glory to which her son was called.
The child was entrusted to Irish monks living at Glastonbury for his education.
He showed a desire for study in all areas of learning, but especially an ardent piety.
Having received minor orders, he entered the service of his uncle Athelhome, Archbishop
of Canterbury, and was then at the court of King Athelstan.
Some of the courtiers, jealous of the favor enjoyed by the young cleric, having accused
him of studying pagan literature and dabbling in magic, he left the court and went to take
refuge in Winchester with Bishop Alpha, whose kinsmen by marriage he was.
With the latter's encouragement, Dunston became a monk and was ordained priest.
He then withdrew to Glastonbury to live as a hermit, near the monastery which was then
in ruins.
The fame of his holiness of life began to spread in the area, and he was unspearing in
his counsels to Ethelflad, the king's niece, who at her death left him her large fortune.
After Athelstan's death, the new king, Edmund I, summoned the hermit to make him one of
his privy counselors.
This favor produced further calumny which resulted in his dismissal from court.
Having miraculously escaped a hunting accident, the king realized that its cause lay in the
unjust exiling of Dunston, and he made him abbot of the monastery at Glastonbury, which
he restored and at the center of which he founded a school in 943.
Dunston organized the monastery in strict observance of the rule of St. Benedict and had the church
and the monastic buildings rebuilt.
But after only two years, Edmund was assassinated, and his successor, Idrid, summoned the saint
to make him his prime minister.
Showing in this charge a profound sense of the Christian vocation of the kingdom, Dunston
consolidated the authority of the crown, purged out the remnants of paganism, rebuilt
the churches, destroyed during invasions, and was an inspiration for the strict observance
of the Holy Canons in ecclesiastical matters.
During the nine years that he governed, he twice refused to become Archbishop, reckoning
that he must carry out his task.
This was, however, brought to a standstill by the death of King Idrid in 955, and Idwig's
accession to the throne.
He was a corrupt man and was strongly opposed to the reforms introduced by the saint, hounded
by the resentment of one of the King's mistresses, the Holy Abbott was forced to flee to Flanders
to the monastery of Blandinium near Ghand, where he found the time to make an intensive study
of the monastic movement that stemmed from clunny.
This exile, however, only lasted a short time, towards the end of 957, the Mercians and
Northumbrians, infuriated by Idwig's disilluteness, deposed him and placed his brother Edgar
at the head of the northern part of the kingdom.
Edgar had danced and consecrated Bishop of Booster, and in the following year, added the Episcopal
seat of London in 959.
On Idwig's death, Edgar, being left as sole ruler, immediately made the saint Archbishop
of Canterbury, the prince, and primate of the kingdom of England.
Having received from Rome, the pallium sent by Pope John XI who made him his legate, Dunston
placed competent bishops and abbots in charge of the dioceses and monasteries of which he
restored a great number, ensuring the application of just laws and organized missions in Scandinavia.
Despite this intensive activity, he in no way neglected his interests in the copying of
manuscripts and in all aspects of the arts, becoming known as a patron of many arts and
crafts, blacksmiths, gold and silversmiths, jewelers, musicians, etc.
His political activity was sealed by the solemn coronation of King Edgar in Bath in 973.
Two years later, the king died, and it was through St. Dunston's influence that his
oldest son Edward succeeded to the throne.
On the death of the latter, as the victim of a conspiracy in 979, St. Dunston withdrew
to Canterbury.
He left the Abbey rarely, notably for the translation of St. Edward's relics to Schaff's
library Abbey.
He spent his last years in prayer, encouraging the founding of schools and monasteries and
himself taught in the cathedral school when he was not busy in the bell foundry or copying
manuscripts.
Having been informed beforehand by an angel in a vision, he gave his soul into God's hands
on Saturday the 19th of May in 988.
The veneration of this saint who had dominated the ecclesiastical and political life of the
10th century spread rapidly among the people, and his tomb in Canterbury became a place of
national pilgrimage until its destruction in 1508.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.